>>> BACK WITH OUR BREAKING NEWS
AND A POSSIBLE COMPROMISE ON
CAPITOL HILL TO SAVE THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT, AT LEAST
TEMPORARILY, FROM AN ECONOMIC
CATASTROPHE.
THIS POTENTIAL DEAL COMES AS A
DEVASTATING NEW POLL FINDS 55%
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
ACCORDING TO A QUINNIPIAC POLL,
DISAPPROVE OF PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
HANDLING OF THE ECONOMY.
AND THE PRESIDENT IS SEEING THE
LOWEST SCORE ON HIS JOB
PERFORMANCE SINCE TAKING OFFICE.
ONLY 38% APPROVAL.
NOW AS CNN'S JEFF ZELENY
REPORTS, VOTERS IN MICHIGAN ARE
TELLING HIM THEIR PATIENCE IS
RUNNING THIN.
>> HEALTHY AND DYSFUNCTIONAL
FAMILY TO AIR YOUR GRIEVANCES,
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S SMART.
>> Reporter: THE DYSFUNCTIONAL
FAMILY LAURIE GOLDMAN IS TALKING
ABOUT IS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND ITS MESSY DIVIDE IN
WASHINGTON.
>> I THINK WE HAVE TO BE MORE
PRAGMATIC ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO
AND WHAT WE CAN'T DO.
>> Reporter: SHE CAMPAIGNED FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND REMAINS
HOPEFUL HE CAN UNIFY THE PARTY
AROUND HIS DOMESTIC AGENDA.
NOW ENDANGERED BY DISAGREEMENTS
AMONG PROGRESSIVE AND MODERATE
DEMOCRATS.
BIDEN CAME TO MICHIGAN ON
TUESDAY, EAGER TO TAKE THE
CONVERSATION INTO THE COUNTRY.
>> I WANT THOSE JOBS HERE IN
MICHIGAN.
NOT HALFWAY AROUND THE GLOBE.
>> Reporter: IT WAS HIS FOURTH
PRESIDENTIAL VISIT TO A STATE HE
NARROWLY WON LAST YEAR.
VOTERS HERE SAY THEY'RE WATCHING
HIM CAREFULLY WITH OPTIMISM --
>> HE'S BEEN REALLY, REALLY
GOOD, YOU KNOW, HE'S WILLING TO
TELL THE TRUTH, REGARDLESS OF
POLITICAL CONSEQUENCES.
>> Reporter: AND SKEPTICISM.
>> I HAVE TO GIVE HIM MIXED
REVIEWS.
>> Reporter: KEN, AN
INDEPENDENT, AND SUSAN SHARON, A
REPUBLICAN, ARE LONGTIME
FRIENDS.
HE BELIEVES BIDEN HAS RESTORED
COMPETENCE TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> I THINK HE'S TRYING TO RUN AS
A FAIR DEALER.
HE'S TRYING TO WORK WITH THE
OTHER SIDE.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE OTHER SIDE, I
DON'T THINK, IS INTERESTED IN
WORKING WITH HIM.
>> Reporter: SHE WORRIES ABOUT
THE COST OF BIDEN'S PROGRAMS.
>> I CAN'T EVEN FATHOM A
TRILLION DOLLARS AND YET -- JUST
GOING OUT LIKE NO BIG DEAL.
>> Reporter: AFTER A SUMMER OF
SETBACKS ON AFGHANISTAN AND
COVID, THE PRESIDENT IS
SCRAMBLING TO PROVE HIS PARTY
CAN GOVERN.
CONGRESSWOMAN ELISSA SLOTKIN
EXCUSE DISTRICT BIDEN VISITED,
FEARS THE GRIDLOCK IN THE
CAPITOL WILL TURN OFF SOME
VOTERS.
>> DO I WISH WE WERE MORE
PRODUCTIVE?
YEAH.
AM I FIGHTING AND TRYING TO PUSH
PEOPLE THAT WAY?
YES.
>> Reporter: THE HOSTILITY
OUTSIDE THE UNION TRAINING
CENTER DID NOT ESCAPE BIDEN'S
EYE.
>> NOTWITHSTANDING SOME OF THE
EYES I SAW.
THAT'S WHY 81 MILLION AMERICANS
VOTED FOR ME.
>> Reporter: BUT HE FIRMLY
BELIEVES HIS INDIVIDUAL ECONOMIC
PLANS HAVE BROAD APPEAL.
SEVERAL BIDEN SUPPORTERS HERE
SAY THEY ARE WILLING TO BE
PATIENT.
>> I DON'T AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING, BUT I KNOW HIS HEART
IS RIGHT.
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT.
>> Reporter: LAURIE GOLDMAN IS,
TOO, BUT SHE BELIEVES BIDEN MUST
MAKE HIS CASE MORE FORCEFULLY.
>> TAKE A PAGE FROM THE TRUMP
PLAYBOOK.
LESS APOLOGIZING.
MORE EXPLAINING, AND GET MORE
DONE.
>> Reporter: FROM THE TRUMP
PLAYBOOK?
>> YEAH.
HE NEVER APOLOGIZED FOR
ANYTHING.
I'D LIKE HIM TO GET OUT THERE
AND JUST CHARGE AHEAD.
>> Reporter: JAKE, YOU MENTIONED
THOSE DECLINING POLL NUMBERS.
THOSE NUMBERS COME ALIVE WHEN
YOU TALK WITH VOTERS HERE IN
MICHIGAN.
ONE THING ALSO IS TRUE TALKING
TO INDEPENDENT AND DEMOCRATIC
VOTERS AS WELL.
THEY BELIEVE IF PRESIDENT BIDEN
AND DEMOCRATS COME TOGETHER TO
PASS SOME OF THIS AGENDA IT IS
BROADLY POPULAR.
SO THE WHITE HOUSE AT LEAST
HOPES THOSE NUMBERS WOULD GO UP.
BUT THAT, OF COURSE, IS VERY
MUCH AN OPEN QUESTION.
BECAUSE AS WE KNOW, THERE IS
STILL NO DEAL ON THE BIDEN
ECONOMIC PLAN.
JAKE?
>> JEFF ZELENY IN DETROIT,
THANKS SO MUCH.
>>> LET'S DISCUSS THIS WITH
BARBARA LEE OF CALIFORNIA, WHO
IS ON THE CONGRESSIONAL
PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS.
CONGRESSWOMAN, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
LET'S START OFF WITH THIS
QUINNIPIAC POLL SHOWING THAT
MORE THAN HALF OF AMERICANS,
55%, SAY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT COMPETENT
WHEN IT COMES TO RUNNING THE
GOVERNMENT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT LAST WEEK'S
FAILURE TO GET AN INFRASTRUCTURE
DEAL AND THE LARGER BUILD BACK
BETTER SPENDING PACKAGE AS
PROMISED BY DEMOCRATIC
LEADERSHIP, AS PROMISED BY THE
WHITE HOUSE, ARE YOU SURPRISED
BY THESE NUMBERS?
>> THANK YOU, JAKE FOR HAVING ME
WITH YOU THIS AFTERNOON.
LET ME TELL YOU, THIS PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN FIGHTING FROM DAY ONE
VERY HARD ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
NOW WHAT I HAVE TO SAY IS THIS.
PEOPLE ARE REALLY MORE FAMILIAR
WITH THE LAST FOUR YEARS IN
TERMS OF DICTATORIAL, AUTOCRATIC
RULE OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE BY
DONALD TRUMP.
AND SO THIS PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
TRYING FOR THE LAST TEN MONTHS
TO MAKE SURE THAT HE BRINGS THE
COUNTRY TOGETHER ON BEHALF OF
EVERYONE IN OUR COUNTRY AND THE
AGENDA THAT HE CAMPAIGNED ON.
YES, IT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
NO ONE SAID IT WAS GOING TO BE
EASY, BUT I TELL YOU ONE THING.
HE'S BEEN FIGHTING EVERY DAY TO
BRING CONSENSUS TO THE CAUCUS AS
WELL AS OUR SPEAKER AND, IN
FACT, 96%, 97% WE'RE TOGETHER.
AND SO FOCUSING ON THE GLASS
HALF EMPTY, I THINK, IS WHAT
PEOPLE ARE DOING BECAUSE THEY
ARE FRUSTRATED.
THEY WANT TO SEE SOMETHING
HAPPEN RIGHT AWAY BECAUSE WE'RE
STILL LIVING IN A PANDEMIC.
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND LIVELIHOODS
ARE AT STAKE AND THEY WANT TO
SEE US GET SOMETHING DONE.
BUT WE'RE DOING THAT.
BUT I UNDERSTAND WHERE PEOPLE
ARE COMING FROM, BUT I HAVE TO
JUST TELL YOU, I KNOW THIS
PRESIDENT.
I'VE BEEN IN MEETINGS WITH HIM
AND I KNOW HE'S DOING EVERYTHING
HE CAN DO TO GET THIS AGENDA
PASSED BECAUSE IT IS AN ECONOMIC
AGENDA THAT'S GOING TO BRING
JOBS AND BRING THE ECONOMY BACK.
>> SO YOU WERE AMONG THE
LAWMAKERS WHO SPOKE WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN ON MONDAY.
HE SAYS HE THINKS THIS BUILD
BACK BETTER SPENDING PACKAGE TO
IMPROVE THE SOCIAL SAFETY NET,
TO SPEND MORE MONEY ON PROGRAMS
LIKE DAY CARE, CHILD CARE AND
ELDER CARE AND THE LIKE, HE
THINKS IT NEEDS TO BE, IN ORDER
TO PASS, NOT $3.5 TRILLION BUT
SOMEWHERE AROUND $2 TRILLION,
BETWEEN $1.9 TRILLION AND $2.2
TRILLION.
WOULD YOU -- THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU
WANT, BUT WOULD YOU BE WILLING
TO GO ALONG WITH THAT NUMBER IN
ORDER TO GET THIS ENTIRE AGENDA
PASSED?
>> JAKE, LET ME ANSWER IT LIKE
THIS.
FIRST OF ALL, THIS IS AN
ECONOMIC AGENDA AND PEOPLE TALK
AND PUT IT IN CONTEXT OF A
SOCIAL AGENDA BUT THIS IS AN
ECONOMIC AGENDA.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT REDUCING
POVERTY.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A LIVING
WAGE, GOOD PAYING UNION JOBS,
ADDRESSING THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ADDRESSING
THE HOUSING CRISIS.
IT'S GOING TO CREATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, GOOD PAYING JOBS.
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE GOING TO
GET PEOPLE JOBS AND HELP THEM
PULL THEIR LIVES TOGETHER.
AND SO WHATEVER NUMBER WE COME
UP WITH IS GOING TO BE WHO WINS,
WHO LOSES, RIGHT?
IF THE NUMBERS GO DOWN.
SO WE HAVE TO MAKE SOME
DECISIONS.
DO WE WANT TO CUT BACK ON
REDUCING CHILD POVERTY?
DO WE WANT TO CUT BACK ON OUR
ELDER CARE?
CUT BACK ON PROVIDING A LIVING
WAGE FOR PRIMARILY BLACK AND
BROWN WOMEN AND MEN WHO WORK IN
THE CARE ECONOMY.
DO WE WANT TO CUT BACK ON
WORKFORCE TRAINING WHICH WOULD
GIVE PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO HAVE
BEEN SHUT OUT IN MANY WAYS FROM
THE INFRASTRUCTURE EFFORTS IN
THE COUNTRY BECAUSE OF THE
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING
PROGRAMS.
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO TO MAKE SURE
WE INCLUDE EVERYONE IN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> BUT I GUESS MY QUESTION FOR
YOU IS, YOU CAN'T GET IT PASSED.
YOU CAN'T GET IT THROUGH MANCHIN
AND SINEMA IN THE SENATE IN
ORDER -- AT THE LEVEL YOU WANT.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GO ALONG
WITH IT.
WILL THE HOUSE PROGRESSIVE
CAUCUS BE WILLING TO COME DOWN
TO AROUND $2 TRILLION IN ORDER
TO GET AT LEAST THAT $2 TRILLION
OUT THE DOOR TO HELP PEOPLE THE
WAY YOU DESCRIBE?
>> WELL, WE'VE SAID EARLY ON,
YOU KNOW, WHAT DO THE SENATORS
WANT TO TAKE OFF OF THE TABLE?
WE RECOGNIZE THE PRACTICALITY OF
THE NEGOTIATIONS THAT HAVE TO
TAKE PLACE.
WE JUST WANT TO KNOW WHO LOSES,
WHO WINS, AND WE WANT TO KNOW
HOW WE CAN MOVE FORWARD ON OUR
PRIORITIES.
REMEMBER, RACIAL EQUITY AND
GENDER EQUITY IS SO IMPORTANT IN
THIS OVERALL PLAN.
IT'S AN ECONOMIC PLAN THAT'S
GOING TO HELP REPAIR MUCH OF THE
DAMAGE OF THE PAST DECADES.
AND SO PEOPLE DESERVE TO BE ABLE
TO KNOW THAT THEIR GOVERNMENT IS
GOING TO WORK FOR THEM
REGARDLESS OF WHO THEY ARE AND
WHAT THEIR BACKGROUND IS AND
WHERE THEY LIVE.
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
NEGOTIATING IT.
SO WE HAVE TO SEE WHO WINS AND
WHO LOSES.
AND IT'S PAID FOR.
>> SENATOR JOE MANCHIN WOULD NOT
COMMIT TO THE NEW OCTOBER 31st
DEADLINE SET BY DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS TO FIND A DEAL ON THIS
BILL.
IS IT REALISTIC TO THINK THIS
WILL BE CELTED BY THE END OF THE
MONTH?
>> LOOK, THIS IS EVOLVING AS WE
SPEAK.
YOU KNOW HOW THESE NEGOTIATIONS
GO.
AND WE ARE WORKING DAY AND
NIGHT, HOPEFULLY IT WILL BE
SETTLED BY OCTOBER 31st.
AGAIN GOING BACK TO WHAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED.
THEY NEED SOMETHING THAT'S GOING
TO CHANGE THEIR LIVES RIGHT
AWAY.
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO HELP
THEM FEED THEIR FAMILIES AND
HELP THEM GET GOOD PAYING JOBS.
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO HELP
YOUNG PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WE'RE
ADDRESSING THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
SO WE HAVE TO DO A LOT VERY
QUICKLY.
SO I'M HOPING WE CAN DO THIS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE BUT THESE
NEGOTIATIONS ARE TAKING PLACE
AMONGST DIFFERENT INDIVIDUALS,
DIFFERENT MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
WHO HAVE DIFFERENT POINTS OF
VIEWS.
THIS IS WHAT DEMOCRACY SHOULD BE
ABOUT.
THIS IS HOW YOUR GOVERNMENT
WORKS.
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
WE'RE MOVING TOWARD A VERY
POSITIVE CONCLUSION WHENEVER
THAT IS BY BRINGING CONSENSUS
AND UNITY AT LEAST FOR